Speaking of >> content creators, Denims, Frogen, and Casey
Tron. And I believe recently he has now included Shawn de Black
in his lawsuit.
Just to make sure everyone knows, it's not a Okay. >> Didn't
he take back Sha Black like
>> or is Shondaanda Black like >> he did? Yeah. He
didn't actually say an old video. >> We've recently he
has now included Shawn Black in his lawsuit just to make sure
>> Oh, so this is 17 hours ago. When did this get made?
>> Like for today, I believe. I think it was from a stream.
It's like pre-record thing. I think >> everyone knows it's
not a
>> I don't know that's relevant. >> It's not a sexism.
>> And on the surface, let's be clear, it looks petty as
because no one would ever accuse you. >> I'm sorry. I I'm
already snarking. I'm >> I'm sorry to watch that again.
It's not a
and on the surface,
let's be clear, Lulu's petty is. Are you
>> Why? [laughter] >> Why is she like the hair flip?
>> Such a sexist alien. >> I've seen I've seen I've
seen a clip where a woman flipped her hair like this. Right,
guys?
>> Let's be clear. Why did she actually turned her head
completely away from the camera and continued talking
[laughter] >> petty as did she practice this maneuver?
>> I don't know. >> Because I don't know. >> No
one would ever accuse Ethan Klein of not being petty.
>> It's not like his entire career is largely being a petty
as Here's the problem with petty as it's like the Britney Ventes
of the internet. Okay,
you love to see it. Hate to be the victim of it. And when they
pick the right person to be the petty that they are, it's >> satisfying.
What did >> I think most people who will watch this for
Ethan Klein or any of the people involved don't know Britney
Benty.
>> Entirely possible. >> I think what she's trying
to say is like she likes it when people snark in a direction
against people she dislikes. >> I think
the point >> I think everyone that will watch this video
will know Britney Venty.
I think pretty much every Destiny fan watches knows Britney Venty,
right? >> Oh, well, Destiny fans, but I'm
watch Anyone else watching Aerodite like Okay, I see. I see where
you're going.
>> fine. It feels welld deserved. And even though you watch
it and you're like, "Ooh, that's a little too far." You know,
it feels good. It feels good cuz the person deserves it. Like
when Britney Venty went into Pearl on the Color theory stuff.
Brutal. Savage. everyone. You can just see it. She's not wrong.
You know that Pearl watched that and it just it went right in.
But also, Pearl runs around calling all women fat, hitting the
wall, and stupid, and shouldn't have the right to vote. So, there's
a balancing of like, well, you're already an [__]
so you're going to get what you dish. These three people are
being sued because they colluded with H3 mods to basically reream
Ethan's expose of Assan [__] after the blowup.
what to >> just totally unproven statement there that they
colluded with H3 mods just isn't shown anywhere. >> Uh
yeah. Yeah. I assume she's going to go into like some of the
facts of this. Although she technically already said Shondaanda
Black was included which is >> Like we're already off on
just >> this is Is this even a stream thing? Was this like
live? >> No, this is I think it's just
>> There's no way she scripted this content and got like
the one of the first facts she laid out wrong. >> Well,
that's the thing. She obviously didn't script it. Somebody else
must
>> I don't think she scoped it. It seems like it's just
a pre-recorded thing that she sort of done off the cuff with
probably maybe like a couple like takes of different stuff. Like,
you know, she'll have just sat down,
riff, maybe made the same line, delivered it a few different
ways, a few different times, and taking the best one. Yeah, it's
sort of edited up, but it's not scripted.
>> Oh, so you you think she did multiple takes of this
hair flip?
>> I think that's possible. I think that's in fact likely.
Not just possible, likely. I think she probably delivered that
line once was like, "Oh, I kind of I think that line's good.
I I want to deliver a different way." And then the hair flick
was like, "Yeah, that's good." [laughter]
>> And then I think she probably put in a message to her
editor specifically.
Hey, can you make sure there's like a line at the start of the
video where I do it twice and I use the I do a hair flick one
time. Can Can you use the hair flick
>> Yeah. Want to make sure you got that for sure. Um, also
don't use the zoomed in version. Make sure you zoom out. Okay,
I look great in this dress. >> With the explicit
>> verbalized intention to steal views from Ethan Klein
and to ensure that he got less money as a result of his expose.
So, it was a watch party to actively block views from Ethan Klein's
content. Now, you might be thinking, is that
And the answer to that is
I don't know. I'm not a lawyer. But a more important question
because the thing that I am concerned here being >> she's
gonna go to a lawyer to get to get great advice. >> She's
not going to go to >> to her friend who you know obly she
knows is very intelligent. Instead she's going to go to a YouTube
>> so much sense. >> That that would make that make
way too much sense. In fact I I fear. So instead, unfortunately,
>> no, the the the go east lawyer instead
>> And unfortunately, we also know >> I I have a
good under a good inkling, you know, a feeling that she could
have easily gone to her friend, but she already probably knew
that her friend didn't have quite the right opinion. Not >> right
opinion. Yeah. Did not have the opinion that she needed for this
video.
>> Didn't even need to go to them, though, cuz they made
a video debunking the the lady boy lawyer. I think like literally
this exact video that she's about to watch and like
>> who dives into psychology and philosophy and politics
is is it the right thing to do and the answer to that is >> no
don't do that don't do that [__] that's [__]
up don't do that
>> dude like you see what I mean like it's
>> it's like not >> streamed it is pre-recorded but
it's not scripted either she's just like riffing and doing bits
alone
>> and then sending the footage to her editor to make something
comprehensible out of. >> It's criminal that she's making
this video that is a Pixie imitation after what she did to Pixie.
Okay. It's criminal that she's going to try to take Pixie's format
so transparently.
>> What do you mean after what she did to Pixie? She only
helped Pixie.
>> One, I don't even I'm not even going to stand on that.
But she did not only help Pixie. Okay. There's some some not
great stuff there. All right. >> but I've been assur I've
been assured >> the audacity calling. >> I just wanted
to point out that she's clearly taking the audacity thing and
she's using it.
>> Hopefully it goes well. >> Don't do that. Don't
do that [__] That's [__] up. Don't do
that.
>> Dude, I can't get over that peak of the audio there.
You >> don't do that. Don't do that [__]
>> It's like peaking crackly audio for her >> It's
because
She doesn't have a room mic. Like, if you're going to be standing
back and screaming like that, you need a microphone that captures
the whole room.
>> But she just has her I think she has
>> Yeah. With the game turned up, we're getting pumped.
>> So, that's why this sounds
pumped. Let's >> That's not great. >> [__]
up. Don't do that. However, >> really, isn't it? In a juicy
juicy development, it turns out that Reddit itself might be implicated
because while there are multiple H3 snark mods that are implicated
within the lawsuit, obviously the identity of that person has
to be found for them to be properly sued. However, we've just
learned that it may be the case that one of the H3 Snark mods
that are implicated in the lawsuit, Roman P, may in fact also
be a Reddit staff member. Let me let Mindset tell you. absolutely
legally cooked. We're going to get into a bombshell leak that
will change everything.
>> She's so dumb, bro. >> How did nobody How did
nobody tell her that like this video is >> like widely
debunked? Like widely mocked and debunked
>> and that this guy's like falling apart. It's like he
he's like actually having his own breakdown and meltdown and
like
>> I'm looking at his eyes looking everywhere on the screen
except [laughter] for where her camera is.
>> I can't not see it now. It's so >> the legal mindset
where you teach you to be your own judge. So, we've been going
through the case of Ethan Klein versus the orbiters of Hassan,
including the Reddit mods. And in that, we've been looking at
what's going on with them, and also their legal liability. And
we now have a leak, something that was brought to my attention,
and something that, as far as I know, nobody else may know about
this, although Ethan Klein will soon be very, very, very aware
of this. Uh, and I'm sure his lawyers are going to be very, very
interested in this because it blows wide open this case. Once
again, Ethan Klein suing for copyright infringement and he has
massive power behind that lawsuit because the damages are in
the hundreds of thousands of dollars, potentially millions, right?
If you look at scope of damages from all these creators, leeching
revenue, leaving leeing potential sponsorships, etc. Taking his
content wholesale, he's got >> I just I love that this
whole like lawsuit or at least the the Denim's version. I don't
know which version this is because it's not some separate thing
against It's got to be the Denim's version, right? Of the lawsuit.
>> Sure. Yeah, >> cuz
cuz like basically this is all to go after Denims or Denims was
the primary plaintiff. Like I don't know,
they still haven't even come close. They haven't even approached
proving any amount of collusion between Denims and these people,
right? These people said we should all go watch Denims instead
of this, but everybody was going to watch the video. They just
linked to her stream. There's no proof that Denims asked them
to do that or had anything to do with it. >> The Denim
is the one that includes people and >> they got us grind.
I'm pretty sure they got us grind. I'm pretty sure >> they
could have gotten a subpoena granted, but like I'm saying that
there is no saying
>> yeah it's like alleged in the lawsuit but they basically
are looking to get DMs. I assume the subpoena is just for Reddit.
I very much doubt they colluded over Reddit. If they colluded
I would guess it's over Discord. I don't know if there's been
a subpoena of Discord. >> They also tried to use the fact
that um she had a tab open of the subreddit.
>> Oh yeah. on her screen. And I think Reddit has its own
DMing system, so they probably want to see that. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Um, honestly, if Denim's like explicitly asked these people
to like set her up in in something, I probably does deserve to
go down. That would be insane. That would be really really really
stupid to do. >> And it also just, you know, that obviously
didn't happen. I don't think personally. I mean,
I feel like her approach to this whole thing would have been
far different if that had happened. >> She's been nothing
but cooperative. So, I would say it's really weird if uh she
did do something fishy with them and she's just been like open
and willing to help and agreeing to like Yeah, my my lawyers
also want to subpoena the
>> You know, to exonerate herself or something. Oh, I didn't.
>> So, how many um >> weren't people People were
saying that she was turning on her own people by like agreeing
her lawyers agreeing to help uh Ethan's?
>> Oh, I'm Yeah, I'm guessing that she probably knows she
didn't collude via anything there and she's probably like, "Yeah,
go get that."
>> Sorry. Go ahead, Queenman. What were you going to say?
>> Yeah. How many viewers get like 3K, right? Like why
why the would a 3K live viewer streamer ever even bother DMing
with a Reddit mod to get a shout out post? Like what what is
even the it's not even worth the time you spend doing >> during
the during the content nuke? I thought she spiked way higher
than 3K. I think she spiked up to like >> Yeah. Well, yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. She did during the content nuke. But I'm saying she's
already a 3K view streamer. She doesn't need a Reddit post on
H3 Sn to tell people that she's a [__] >> She
doesn't need to coordinate at all. She's like a big streamer.
She literally said she was >> It's literally not worth
the time to get that post made to like coordinate for it. Like
>> um I mean I've
>> It's probably not. And I think here's the thing is
I I'm guessing that if Denims has like a dashboard that says
where her viewers were coming from, I'm guessing she could actually
go to Twitch and say, "Can I get this an the analytics like cut
down for like this day or something?" And I'm almost positive
you're going to see a flow from like Discord and other places
of Hassan fans who wasn't live that day going and sharing amongst
themselves. Oh, Denims is covering it. Denims is covering it.
>> I think like those like the idea that there's a text
post like a text post with a bunch of links in it that's just
like a shout out to some streams. Like that's not picking up
in any algorithm or anything. No one's posting that around. That'll
sit there on the on the page. No one gives a [__]
>> Like that's not something that's going to pop off people.
It's like 30 people. >> Like it's not. >> Yeah. I
just don't think many people are going to check the H3 Snark
page. Yeah, it's like a niche thing.
They do they do not want to give Ethan views, but I just Yeah,
I don't see them being a massive contributor in any way. Got
massive massive liability. There's even potential punitive damages
based on the intent, right? Based on the fact that these people
had malicious intent to steal his content. So, looking at that,
>> that's wrong. >> We had Reddit mods that were
in this case, right? Cuz we obviously know Casey >> in
the words of Emmy, he can't do that. He can't do that. >> Frogen,
all of these casting characters are liable. But the Reddit mods
are a big part of this. This is, by the way, totally not AI and
totally inaccurate an accurate photo of a Reddit moderator. I
think it's very much real to life. But the Reddit moderators
were hoping to hide. They were hoping to cower beyond their,
you know, behind their internet >> It's my friend Meat,
>> right? They have power in the fact that they are anonymous
and that nobody knows them and they can reach out and say things
and do whatever, but now they're being exposed. Now they're being
called out and they are terrified. They're absolutely
uh scared that they're going to be exposed in this and they filed
a motion of 700 pages trying to hide from responsibility. Well,
that's not going to happen. Their identity is going to come out.
And one thing that's been coming out is who these people are
exactly. And the big news is that beyond all comprehension, we
now have proof that Reddit is directly tied to these moderators
which are going to be sued. So, let's go into here uh to this.
Ooh. Ooh. Ooh. Now, one very quick thing to say. This one's going
to be a little bit spicy. Okay. If you >> The camera
pivots.
Did she just show that she has three different camera
>> Yeah, these are all these would all be on her like stream
deck or something. >> How often does she even stream? >> This
one seem to be a little bit spicy.
>> I don't know. And I don't know why.
I don't know.
Maybe m maybe it's just for like this format of video.
Does she do these? Hold on. [laughter] I I super don't want to
call you out, Kger. Does she do this during the live stream?
I'm sorry. I >> Oh, okay. >> I'm not even talking.
I'm just curious. >> You know what? Never mind. Don't answer
just in case. >> Okay. If you weaponize your anonymity
in such a way that you are like personally trying to destroy
people's lives or trying to destroy their business, I don't think
you deserve anonymity anymore. I don't want you to be like doxed
and harassed in the same way that we dox and harass people. But
I absolutely
want your identity be found in a lawsuit. >> We
Yeah, we >> Yeah, we
>> Yeah. Um, kind of odd. And
I'm just curious how she thinks that if somebody's anonymous,
how do you take away that anonymity? And why are you taking away
that anonymity? Why do you think that anonymity should be taken
away? Why do you think that person is anonymous? What do you
think happens when you take that anonymity away by yourself,
the person who feels like they're trying to destroy your business?
What h you you feel that way? What happens when you strip away
their >> What do you think this anonymous person is doing
to your like livelihood?
>> I Yeah, I'm not sure.
She's doing a lot of I think we all can see what she's doing
here though. >> Or trying to destroy their business.
>> Trying to destroy their business. This seems to be echoing.
This seems to be echoing some other, you know,
Oh, some complete that I've seen on the internet. Um, if you're
trying to destroy someone's business, they have the right to
defensively dox you. That is defensive doxing. Actually, this
is She's I believe she's just giving the defensive doxing argument
right now,
like directly.
>> Yeah, it's pretty stupid. >> I don't think you
deserve anonymity anymore. I don't want you to be like doxed
and harassed in the same way that we do and harass people, but
I absolutely
want your identity to be found in a lawsuit and for that to be
dropped and smeared everywhere. I >> I don't want you doxed
and harassed, but I do want your identity
released. Does she understand >> which is doxing and then
I want you smeared which is harassment. >> No. Does she
understand what smearing
smearing implies like a lying about that person dishonest? You're
that's not smearing. If they are if they're included in a lawsuit
because they did something wrong >> and they got held accountable
for it. >> You're not smearing. You're just you
you're just acknowledging what this person did.
Is this whole thing is to misuse words? >> I Oh, you think
that she couldn't possibly be arguing this? She's just misusing
words. >> I think she's just having fun misusing
>> Maybe I don't know. >> It's so easy to just have
a take, oh, I I don't think that instant animity should go so
far as to protect you from legitimate lawsuits.
And like that's so reasonable. Why Why does she have to have
this like >> this like Yeah, exactly. Why? Why? It's like
so blatant that it's just oh actually it's awesome that Destiny
docks anyone criticizes us. Anyone anyone that calls me uh
Kyla Maxwell actually deserves to have their address put on the
internet. That that's like what she's thinking and she's trying
to come up with different ways of saying it. Uh and it's like
sickening.
>> I have a real I have a question here that I I actually
want to know the answer to. Do you think she shot this before
the
Do you think she shot this
America event and it was just scheduled to release or do you
think after Destiny brought somebody who called Darius somebody
she knows a hard rar 10 ft away from her 5t away from her right
after that got all set up you know it's another thing Arerodite
has to go and like deal with people saying oh there there goes
Destiny humiliating you again for being close to him being like
a business associate of his and then after that she releases
a video she shoots and releases is a video where she's explicitly
defending his like doxing. I just I don't I don't see how that
could be possible.
I
would she really double down? I feel like she had to have shot
>> I think she would double down now.
>> Maybe they get through the little hiccup of being humiliated
and she realizes um
this side is just like better than the other side. So we'll get
through our
>> Maybe
she would defend his doxing either way.
Yeah, probably. >> But then just wait for it. Just wait
for it. In two years, she's going to have like a Lwig video.
I wouldn't even go to this guy's funeral. Okay. It was just like
business associates actually. >> you cannot. We're just
past it. You can't keep abusing anonymity in the way that people
have. Uh hot take. I know a lot of people disagree, but uh the
>> she referenced Emirou, an old Emir quote, and the video
is >> people who weaponize their anonymity in this way
get caught. >> These are screenshots that were forwarded
to me. Now, you have one of these individuals here, one of these
mods, nicknamed Roman P, who's uh listed in the lawsuit, right?
So, we're going to look at these uh these text messages or these
screenshots which were sent over to me before they were deleted,
right? Because once again, they were going back and deleting
and sweeping these things up. But now, we've got conclusive proof
here. That kind of nails them uh nails them in here. So, them
saying, "So, he thinks he could sue Asmin and XQC, but he doesn't
want to sue them. Why? Surely the reaction videos stole more
views from him. Is this kind of admission? He doesn't care about
any potential financial damage, only about personal beef." And
then someone responds, "Did you know you're mentioned in the
lawsuit? just clicked on the first one, skimmed around it and
saw Roman P. So this moderator, this is the head moderator of
this uh of the subreddit um is named and they go, "Oh my god,
thank you for telling me. This is the funniest [__]
ever. I can't believe this." >> When anybody on the internet
finds out that they might be implicated in a lawsuit and it's
like pretty serious what they're being implicated with and they
say, "Oh my gosh, this is the funniest ever." Just know they
are actively pooping their pants as they type that and they're
never cleaning it up because they don't shower because they're
a Reddit mod. >> Guess what? It's not going to be funny
for them for very long. It's funny for me. It's hilarious for
me. Uh then you've got them over here uh saying, "I can't believe
you're outing yourself like this. Classic mistake of criminals
restraining to the scene of the crime." Um so you know, Roman
P says, "Cats out of the
>> Sorry, I missed. Just uh let me roll this back." They
type that >> and they're never cleaning it up because they
don't shower because they're a Reddit mom. >> Because they're
a Reddit. >> Guess what? It's not going to be funny for
them for very long. It's funny. >> She's not. Sorry. There's
just basically no way. My bad. I was uh Listen, who just got
>> You know, she knows that all of her fans are like Reddit
mods, right? Like that's
>> that's who her fan base is.
>> People who don't shower
>> sit there and watch you. I mean based on her what her
whole show all of the negative comments about you. >> Yeah,
we say we could say this pretty much conclusively based on the
>> only personal beef and then someone >> I said
to see if she bought the whole >> Did you know your mention
in the lawsuit just clicked on the first one, skimmed around
it and saw Roman P. So this moderator, this is the head moderator
of this uh of the subreddit um is named and they go, "Oh my god,
thank you for telling me this is the funniest ever. I can't believe
this." When anybody on the internet finds out that they might
be implicated in a lawsuit and it's like pretty serious what
they're being implicated with and they say, "Oh my gosh, this
is the funniest [__] ever." Just know they are actively
pooping their pants as they type that and they're never cleaning
it up. >> I see. I see. She's saying they're not scared.
They're not there >> because they don't shower because
they're a Reddit mod. >> Guess what? It's not going to
be funny for them for very long. It's funny for me. It's hilarious
for me. Uh then you've got them over here uh saying, "I can't
believe you're outing yourself like this. Classic mistake of
criminals returning to the sh of the crime." Um so you know,
Roman P says, "Cats out of the bag. Now the real fun begins."
So they're pretending they're going to have fun here now that
they're named in this lawsuit. This is >> Also, I'm sorry.
That's the emoji you want to go with.
>> Just post a minion.
>> Is that the Larry Ellis? >> This is not serious.
That was the Larry >> That was Larry Ellis. going to call.
I thought she was going to call it out as Larry Ellison. I I
thought she was actually going to do that, but she's >> Ellison.
Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Wait,
>> You want to go with
just post a minion at that point?
Just just do it. >> Uh certainly this is not going to be
fun. We're going to see why. Uh next, um you see here some uh
>> she's calling him cringe for posting that emote. cast
of characters including uh a very well-known Hassan Orbiter in
stand here uh who's saying we're gonna build a shield wall for
you uh Roman P thanking this questionable individual uh who is
definitely a separate person not me on just another one of my
sock puppet accounts that was actually this individual that would
be even worse for Reddit because it
>> no none of it no none of this raises yeah none of this
could be a joke this all seems very serious >> hirings
all >> man god
can you imagine If Roman P ends up being bad empanada,
if you don't know who Bad Empanada is,
is this person serious?
>> She is like a glutton for punishment,
>> I don't I love I love I love doxing. I love I love doxing.
I love But I hate hate bad empatada. She just she so badly needs
somebody to do something to her so she can cry about it. I'm
convinced that's why she talks about him so much.
>> That must be so up. Okay. That is like like the fat
kid who has trauma because their prolific predator gym teacher
never tried to touch them, right? >> Okay. Okay. >> I'm
sorry. That's what it's like. She's out here just being like,
"Bad empanada sucks. Bad empanada doxes. Bad empanada ruined
my life. He tried to swap me." And bad empanada just ignores
her all the time. It's like this guy will literally go after
anybody for any reason. He's prolifically gone after President
Sunday, Loader Box. >> Well, it's not that Destiny, everybody.
>> No, she he did reply to her. He's like, "Well, you're
going to go around and find out." But she tried to after he did
that to her. Then she's like, "Do you want to come on to be humanized?
I want to talk to people like you." >> And then he won't.
>> For the record, I have no idea if he actually did anything
>> if he's responsible for any of this. told her no, but
I think he like he replied to her on Twitter with some
>> Oh, I'll have to go look for that.
You're a normal human being and I'm going to destroy that and
I apologize.
>> Wait, what?
>> Bad empanada.
One of his many great jokes he's made is, "Oh, a bunch of babies
and kids now. Where's the video evidence of it? I was looking
to jerk off anyways." Is that real? I've heard that one contested
a
>> What do you mean by that?
>> No idea. >> Why are you saying that? He claims
credit. We don't actually have proof, but he claims credit at
least of being the person who called CPS on Ethan Klein and his
children. Yeah. And he fled Australia to Argentina, and we don't
really know why. So that's weird. Where you going, buddy? Why
you on the run, buddy? So if Roman P
happens to be bad empanada, which I don't think they are the
same person,
>> she so badly wants this guy to do something. It's so
funny if Dude, the worst thing bad empanada could do to not erodite
is unironically just ignoring [laughter] her. >> Yeah,
that that would absolutely destroy her. Like she might stop content
creation. But if they are and they work for Reddit,
yikers,
not good for Reddit.
>> Wait, wait, wait.
>> If they are and they work for Reddit,
did she move away from it being bada? If it's bad if bad empanada
works for
>> I'm I'm not I'm missing some she's saying or something.
>> Where you going, buddy? Why you on the run, buddy? So
if Roman P
happens to be bad empanad which I don't think they are the same
person but if they are and they work for Reddit
yikers
not good for Reddit >> with some questionable characters
in the >> I forgot to point out you know if bad empanel
was talking about off to dead kids or dead kids wouldn't that
be like the worst thing in the world wouldn't you like totally
cut off all associations with somebody who's willing to do
That is absolutely I think frankly there is no greater sin on
earth than making jokes on Twitter. I think you should be going
even further showing the lawsuit showing exactly where they are
named. So highlighting that user use Roman P which is there amongst
other like uh Reich Salamander and H3 Stark Mod team. So they're
clearly named in the lawsuit. You have an admission
a 100% confession right here. They're saying concern level for
you. This whole thing is so odd. Roman P once again the head
moderator saying not concerned at all. Balancing working at Reddit
and being the head moderator for H3 Snark has kind of been stressful
though. We have a confession. >> Imagine if Reddit finds
out that one of the Snark head mods also works for them. Oh,
and what if we find out that they knew about it? That would be
even worse. You can hire somebody and they can do a perfectly
good job and then in their part-time be a [__] weirdo.
>> She's just, by the way, Andrew says this is 100% proof.
This is a confession
and then no alarm bells still. Just no alarms. Alarm bells at
all. >> Alarm bells.
>> I I just want to make a note, okay, that anything you
post on Reddit uh claiming to have done something is 100% true.
That thing happened. That is a confession. And we need to arrest
Ethan Klein for the multiple counts of actual.
Okay, arrest the now. Can we can we arrest the patrol, please?
>> However, let's go into Roman P. At least this account
how much of a weirdo they are. You're probably a person who has
a life, a job, probably a full-time job. You've probably got
friends. That means you probably work at least 40 hours a week.
So you spend most
>> he wildly drastically overestimates the >> of
your waking hours busy out of the house with not a lot of time
to obsess about YouTube >> the same calling show that I
saw like >> on the internet congratulations it's a good
thing you probably also have a couple of hobbies you have friends
you might have some games that you want to play you've got some
leisure games maybe you've got a group hobby game you play league
with your friends and there's like you know discoium story that
you're trying to get through. Maybe you've got a significant
partner, so you're going on dates or you've got friends, you're
going and doing like community events together. We're going >> This
is all her research on humans on the internet, by the way. [laughter]
>> Talking to five people in our audience right now. Talking
to like a total of five or six people.
>> They're like, >> she has a jobs like a partner
and
>> you have hobbies. Your life is fulfilling. You're definitely
not on the verge of suicide. Like multiple [laughter] people
called into my show. a pickle ball together. You've probably
got a life. Which means that even though you're here watching
me and you're a little no life, just kidding.
>> That the limited hours that you have, you probably wouldn't
dedicate it to doing weird things like obsessing over YouTube
content creators. No, I want you to think about your life in
the >> literally the only reason somebody would click on
this video is because they obsess over the lives of internet
content creators.
>> That's it. A lot of people give me money to make fun
of you. >> Wait, to make fun of who?
>> I've gotten a lot of money to make fun of Eric. >> Oh,
[laughter] okay. Yeah, that's unfortunately, you know, part of
having a full-time job may include obsessing about internet commentators,
okay? That's not my fault. That's just me. That's the invisible
hand of the pre-market, okay? Pushing me into doing >> way
that even the most hated content I want you to visualize right
now the content creator that you hate the most. That was a joke,
by the way. >> Wait, you're joking? I'm not joking. I'm
completely serious. >> I do this for the love of the game.
>> Okay, I'm completely serious that I get paid a lot of
money. I feel like people wanted to add time tonight and then
I felt bad cuz they added time explicitly to watch this and then
I wasn't actually doing it and we the timer ran out. So,
>> we're going in over. How much time in your day,
week, month would you dedicate to logging, talking about
on and regularly posting about?
For most of you, the answer is almost none.
Because it's weird.
It's really weird to obsess about YouTube content creators to
that extent in the first place. And it's extra weird
>> to do it when you hate the content
>> No, weird is a lot of the stuff that you post on Instagram.
I'm going to be real. >> That's facts.
>> Also,
[laughter] I I just don't know how is she going to square her
like actual seething hatred for Hassan and her trying to convince
the Democratic party to not reach out to Hassan. Her taking the
same like basically having the same position as Hutch. How do
you square that? I guess you have to do that by convincing yourself
that it is a moral imperative that is political practice to hate
>> Yeah. But then when you start making that making those
claims, then it kind of contradicts a lot of the other things
you do. So all you've got is saying, "Oh, well the people who
do this to me are just like weird." Not making any moral claims.
It's just weird. >> That's really weird to cover somebody
when you hate them, when you don't like them. That's super odd.
That's really >> Why Why don't they like me? I don't know
about you, but when I find a content creator that I really don't
like, the way that I handle it, it's pretty
This is what I do. I'll show you. >> I try to convince
people they're like a threat to the country and a threat to the
threat to democracy and
their constitution and they need to be put in jail or something.
>> Listen, it's totally normal to think that Hassan [__]
is a bigger threat to democracy than Donald Trump, okay? After
Donald Trump was elected into office and started tearing down
every every day.
>> Obsessed and has a has a rational level of hatred for
the people they they didn't count or align.
>> Pretty simple.
This is what I do. I'll show you. Oh, wow. I don't really like
this guy. Guess I'll go back to YouTube and find something else
to watch. That's the end of the whole story. That's all I typically
do. In fact, the only content creators that I have any level
of forethought about or checking in on are content creators that
are somewhat within my social sphere that I have talked to or
have grown to dislike as a result of my relationship to them.
And even then, I don't watch their content. I don't hate post
about them. I don't think about them very often. And I
>> because if you actually engaged back, you would have
to
precisely that engage. and you know you can't engage >> and
that would hurt your ego. >> Yes. It would like crush you.
>> You'd have to admit fault or anything like that or maybe
even apologize >> to explicitly why she just doesn't deal
with any of this stuff >> or maybe deal with like the lies
that you've told about them to other content creators that are
in the same sphere as them. That'd be really difficult. So you
probably just ignore it and move on.
>> You don't either cuz you're normal. Speaking of being
weird, let's look at Roman P. Let's just go through some of his
very normal posts. All right. No, in his co. Fair enough. I'd
probably
>> was that. >> This is going to be a greatest hits.
>> Post that, too. Even Klein a mock Boston Marathon bombing
survivor in a deleted video. Fat juicy juvenile vagina. Wants
to that then fantasizes about orally her. Why did you find this?
Why did you do Why did you find this? Ethan making fun of Anthony
Padilla's tattoo.
>> Not why did you do Why did that >> Why Why did
Ethan say these things? This seems kind of odd. >> Why
did you find Why are you talking about this? Why Why are you
talking about this? >> Why are you so obsessed with this?
Why are you so obsessed with this guy making
comments? Which, by the way, I don't even think that one was.
I forget exactly. This was like on the line or something, but
that's just a crazy response.
>> Commentators roasting being mean to Steiny. All right,
now just talking in here. Talking about the shot collar on the
dog. Apparently, everyone's freaking out about the fact that
there is a dog
a shot collar. He's talking at length about his favorite streamer,
Hassan. madeup shot color they have fantasized Hassan having
is worse than the real pronged color Ethan and Hila have been
using. Don't know why. Don't know what they're talking about
here. In the old clip, Hassan literally says he couldn't bring
himself to use a shot color. What exactly does Ethan think this
proves? Hassan owned a shot color and didn't use it on talking
about Ethan again. Very interesting. He's not even apologizing.
His argumentation is always don't look at the bad thing I have
done. Look at what this person has done. Same thing with his
Zionism.
Remember
Ethan Klein Zionism is I also don't like Israel and think the
war is wrong and think genocide is happening. I just think you
guys are being a little anti-semitic.
That's his Zionism. Just just so we remember. >> Is that
>> the whole having a troll in your name equals everything
you say is fine because you're just trolling argument is beyond
stupid. Ethan would never be okay with someone called CPS troll
making jokes about him.
They also showed their first video ever, chocolate, in which
Ethan smears his underwear with chocolate and eats chocolate
out the back of his underwear in front of Hila's entire videography
class. Why do you know all of this? Why do you know all of this?
Imagine having like this is unironically.
This is like uh oh this this would be like a creationist or like
this is like cultlike, right? literally like denigrating having
knowledge, denigrating like knowing things. Like, hey, you literally
have facts. Don't you feel gross? Wait, what do you mean? >> What
do you Oh, I'm trying to think of like a >> You don't like
this content creator, so you're and you're watching their content?
What is that just like reinforce why you don't like them? Stop
doing that. Just go watch something else. like you you found
like a contradiction and then they didn't handle that well and
then they kept like doubling down on the on the contradiction
and you you kept asking for an answer and they wouldn't engage
and now you don't like them >> and the more you watch the
more you validate your concerns for their character. Yeah. Like
what's wrong with you? Go outside. It's >> Horrible thing
to do. >> Um doing this Trump by the way totally morally
justified. YouTube doesn't matter at all. Just let me make my
money. You're stopping me from making my money. Well, the problem
with Trump is people are people have like short attention spans.
They don't take into consideration everything he does. They get
they get bored of the the bad thing he did here. They stop like
focusing. They have their lives to deal with and stuff like that.
When it comes to Trump pe people aren't paying attention
>> No, you don't understand. You don't understand. Trump's
Trump's lies and stuff, they actually hurt people. They have
real effects. When when content creators lie, that's just a part
of the game. Okay? That's just a part of the game. They don't
hurt anybody with their lies. Just let them lie and contradict
themselves. Doesn't hurt anyone. You're obsessed if you think
otherwise. Wow. >> This many years of lore of some content
creator, but not just this many years of lore, cuz I get it,
like super fans have been. But then, well, let's be clear, the
super fan and the anti-fan of these power levels are the same
person. This is why it's all kind of weird behavior. But I do
feel like there's something uniquely weird that happens where
somebody goes, they were a leftovers
mod, so I'm imagining they liked Ethan Klein at some point in
their career. And you go all the way from liking Ethan Klein
and obsessing about him and learning about him and watching all
of his content to at some point he does something that you off.
[snorts] And so
>> she not wearing pants. I It seems to be the case. >> You
start posting about him constantly. Now, remember how I asked
you to think about, you know, all the things that you do in your
life, all the activities that you have, and how much time you
would have to dedicate. This person apparently has a job working
for Reddit.
>> And they spend I mean, we're like not even through
>> about a 90% chance that that was a joke, by the way.
>> A tiny amount of his >> she hasn't considered
that. Legal Mindset didn't consider that. >> Um or even
how often Ethan comes up. They don't just hate watch a content
creator. They hate post constantly. They remember videos from
years ago of Ethan Klein smearing chocolate in his underwear
and eating it and all sorts of silly things that are strange.
You're a weirdo. You're a freak. I shouldn't even say this. These
are the exact type of people, by the way, that you shouldn't
I'm pretty dumb actually by covering this like this. It's
>> the fact that I I Oh my god. I'm sorry. She wants their
attention.
She's pretending like, "Oh, this might be bad for me." No, she
knows. >> Where does this I I just I would wonder where
this stops. Like, where does this >> Well, because of like
this application
>> You don't make a comment like that on a pre-recorded
video and then post it.
If you're >> Oh, if you're able to have First of all, you
already know that you're doing this every time that you try to
like stoke the flames between you and Bad Empanada.
And then just having this comment here, she's just like hoping
to just have enough bimboism dropped into here that people give
her plausible deniability for being like a rage baiter. >> Yeah,
I think what
um
Yes, it's the rage baiting thing is there. I also think what
Substance just said is also true that it's like clearly trying
to make space. She's basically saying like stop snarking me.
Stop following me around and asking me to be held accountable
for things. Stop learning about Destiny. Stop holding him accountable
for things. It's actually just obsessed weird behavior. We should
just make fun of anyone who knows about the bad things we've
done in the past cuz that's gross and weird and obsessed.
>> Yeah, she's going to be like on an island by herself
with all of the other narcissistic content creators who
are really like pushing
I don't know the like social norms in such a negative direction.
Um, listen. If you if you disagree with something and I can't
even keep doing it. Jesus. I >> gaslighting people who
criticize you just so you don't have to deal with it and because
you know that you have a mob of an audience who will help you
do so and it's fun and funny to them. Sorry. That is more embarrassing
than being somebody who points out
uh something someone said 3 years ago on a video. >> Yeah.
Obviously, >> your gaslighting audience who does it for
fun is way more embarrassing than what you're complaining about
here. >> Yeah, without a doubt. It's uh it it's funny because
the only way you could do this is if you basically enter the
internet with that audience behind you. Otherwise, every I'm
sure everybody else would figure this out, right? >> As
somebody who entered the internet with that audience behind me
and knows exactly what it's like where it's like, >> I
might be wrong on something and people just wouldn't call it
out. And then you have to go out into the world and figure out,
oh, actually people will challenge you on things. And you should
learn how to deal with that. You should welcome that. U >> not
a not a single person who criticized my video on Aerodite
had anything to say about her content. I don't they didn't even
watch it. They would tell me, "Oh, I don't watch her >> It
is actually the same criticism, isn't it? Seems kind of weird
that you're doing that. >> You're obsessed. You're jealous.
Well, what are what are you defending her for? Well, I don't
watch her content. I just >> these same people who laugh
and clap like seals. Throw the mic from PA. Throw the mic from
PA lower. Oh my god, he punched the couch. >> It is much
more embarrassing that you as a content creator have people who
defend you that don't watch you.
>> That's worse. >> Not concerning at all, is it?
[laughter] Why does everybody who defends me say they don't watch
my content? That's very concerning. important that people like
Roman P who are using their anonymity to harass and talk about
and spread rumors about constantly a couple who, let's be clear,
are petty as who I think are right in their lawsuit this time.
Not that they'll legally win, I have no idea. Just that it's
the morally correct decision and just trying to ruin their lives.
You wouldn't act like this in public. This is the town square
now. this is the town square whether we like it or not but we
want to act like it's our like private dwellings and it's like
it's not just make it so that we can subpoena them and find them
simply but now imagine the fallout if it turns out that this
is a person who works for Reddit like the the questions of like
the level of implication for Reddit are actually just kind of
crazy just kind of
>> I actually don't think there's any reason to believe
that this if this person did work for Reddit that they'd be in
like extra trouble or something
um they would have to have some insight into the like cuz I think
the thing is the only thing they could be held liable for maybe
is if this person oversaw the like reporting process and could
have like gotten rid of reports so that nobody could see it if
they're just like a software engineer or something at Reddit.
They don't control anything. Then what liability could Reddit
have? >> Could you imagine if they're like a >> It
would be funny. >> It's been really hard, you know, cleaning
the bathrooms at the Reddit HQ and running this subreddit. [laughter]
>> That would be up. I can't think of a more cursed existence
to be a real life janitor and then go home and be an internet
janitor >> and then and then you end up in someone's lawsuit
and there's and they're just on you because you literally clean
toilets. >> Crazy to think about. But also Reddit,
who the [__] you have hired? It's a really weird
thing to think about the fact that you might meet totally normal
nice people
>> who just like when they go home they're freaks on the
internet. I don't like that. uh
again doesn't know anything about her audience
just like again right away and I'll tell you there are a lot
of people on the internet who go home after like a long day's
work they have like a wife and they join some IRC chat or Discord
chat I guess
Jim Jim Jim >> no but like that's actually there are a
bunch of groups like that where it's just like people who got
on in on the early internet and that's like how they socialize
they just go and talk [__] on the internet. Yeah,
exactly. >> Okay. I don't like that because the internet
is no longer just like your private hobby. If you just like want
to be freaks alone and you don't like impact other people's lives,
that's fine. But a lot of people are using their anonymity in
ways that are impacting people's real lives and is h having like
radicalization effects on society. And I just don't think we
could do it anymore. Okay. This is why when people criticize
me, I want them to come on stream. I want them to cam up. I want
every single person to see what a pathetic sniveling little
>> This is like the most low IQ position ever. The idea
that oh if we shouldn't have instant anonymity then everyone
would be nicer. But no, everyone on Facebook has their real there
and it's it's like probably possibly the most toxic platform
going. So clearly not it this doesn't work. Like the idea that
oh you put your name to it now you're going to act way different.
>> Uh yeah, people just get used to it. They get used to
being especially when you're just like a random commentator in
>> You think you'll just sink into the you you'll like
fade into the background. >> You are you are you are specifically
in your first world privileged problems if you say oh removing
anonymity from the internet will make everything better. Like
for you specifically in your >> like ego fragile ego from
your content
Yeah. Exactly. It's like legit very >> but for >> it's
so easy as well when you're like a content creator that's like
basically all their information is already out there. It's like
it's so easy just say oh yeah what's the point of instant animity?
Yeah of of course you say that as like a Canadian living in America
>> with you know all your already out there
>> not just that you're doing so for money. You're asking
like commentators people who are like just commenting and like
being critical who don't get any money for being critical. You're
asking them to make the same decision you did to expose themselves
that way. >> But not even. I'm just thinking, okay, you're
supposed to be a political commentator. You're supposed to be
like a political activist, right? You're like, "Oh, I'm out.
I'm I'm in real world doing stuff." Uh, do you not understand
why anonymity on the internet has been like a precious
>> to certain demographics? >> Sorry. Sorry. Do you
not understand why it's been necessary almost like uh like clinging
to life value for certain >> She wants all furries. Just
>> not even talking about furries, but yes, it's marginalized
[clears throat] groups, people who are finding community in in
places where they it might they might get targeted or whatever,
right? >> she wants if a gay person in an Arab state says
some like insane about their their leader >> on social
media, they should be able to sue them and dox them and um you
know whatever happens from there is >> Hey, fair game.
>> Maybe shouldn't call your leader on the
>> Stop snarking your dict
>> thing to complain about. >> I missed what you
said. Sorry. Say it again. You know, I just said that this is
the most selfish, privileged
problem to think exists in the world that you could easily solve.
You're shortsighted and you are so pampered. >> Just to
be clear, she I don't think she even I I'm sort of disbelieving
she even thinks that it would solve the problem. I think she
basically knows that she's got a community behind her who will
harass people if their identities are out there, who will try
like whatever they can. And she knows that if people had to choose
between being exposed, their identities being exposed and criticizing
her, they're probably going to choose, sorry,
if they criticize her, their identities would be exposed or something
that they choose to not criticize. They choose to move on. And
that's that's literally everything wrong with my country right
now is the idea that our values and principles, you've got some
cult of personality who is willing to ditch them because it he
thinks it'll benefit them benefit him in the long run and it
erodess at like, you know, I don't know, our freedoms and
where the world is going. Uh yeah, but have you considered that
in order for Aerodite or Counterpoints' family to be happy, they
need to make a lot of money and so principles kind of like don't
really matter that much? >> You know what? You're right.
>> Sue all stay in America. >> Remove anonymity.
>> She shouldn't defend. >> I don't
America's a land of defending pedophiles. It's like it's like
a requirement to get over the border.
>> Jeez. I heard you have to be able to get over the border
>> person to see what a pathetic sniveling little [__]
loser you are. Okay, because in the normal
>> uh she's just like visualizing Queen in her mind while
she says this. By the >> okay, this is why when people
criticize me, I want them to come on stream. I want them to cam
up. I want every single person to see what a pathetic sniveling
>> Hold on, hold on, hold on. Is that not an explicit invite
to for go on her
It sounds like him. >> I feel like she's like directly
calling you out. >> She's like, "That's my name. You should
go to this video and leave a comment. I'm pretty sure I'm pretty
sure she just st me." She said like, "Full legal." >> That's
your name. >> Loser you are. Okay. Because in the normal
town square, right? Think about the heckler that we had at the
UFA event. Everyone saw Rob'more
rocking around screaming the fslur and just refusing to engage
with anyone. Just Wait, are you upset that somebody called someone
at your UFA event a slur? Erdite, is that a problem for you?
>> Being a
I think this is before that happened. So, in her defense, I guess
I guess
[laughter] she still posted this video. That's
>> Nobody thought
he might have a point here. He might be right here. The conservatives
that were there hated him. Everyone hated him. He was a joke.
he was a joke to everyone, but in large part because you could
watch the entirety of normal human behavior which was happening
around him and his refusal to engage with it and just be an antisocial
freak.
Just to be clear, that exact same thing happens on the internet
if you have equal ability to speak, right? So, if you're on a
Twitch panel like H or something, you're just screaming. There
are some people who find that funny, but a lot of people if you're
just if you're just like ruining any conversation happening,
you're just like screaming and talking over everybody and refuse
to let anyone else get a word in, that's not looked on favorably
on the internet. She's comparing like a comment, a commenter
on YouTube or another YouTube commentator who makes a video on
someone to like that guy screaming over people
>> it's not the same thing. It's not even close. They're
like not even remotely the same thing. Also, at the core of it,
you can't make a video complaining about this stuff unless you
watch that content a lot. >> Yeah. And >> you sound
exhausted and annoyed by it. So, you must actually not be doing
what you're saying, which is, "Oh, I don't watch content I don't
want to see." Cuz you're complaining about it.
>> Yeah. Like, she can't She literally just said, "I can't
hear the hecklers."
>> So, why is she Yeah. I don't know why she would even
complain about it.
>> You can't do this on the internet. Here's a pro tip.
Next time if you ever watch a stream and the stream is being
particularly critical towards somebody,
pay attention to the names saying the negative things. It's often
times like 10 different accounts just saying over and over and
over nasty.
They're a lot of the same person. And here's the thing. If that
person had to stand in front of me with their actual own face,
they would be too cowardly to say anything that they're saying
behind the keyboard. They'd be sitting there like do it. >> I
think >> we are crowdfunding a plane ticket for Deep Rama
to Miami.
>> No, sorry. That's
Oh my god. That would be
>> You can't You can't do that. Deepama, they're bringing
back one last Bridges episode. Okay. The most difficult bridge
to build of all. [laughter] >> She's like,
"Oh god." And also, everyone would be able to look at them and
be like, "You're fat. You're stinking. You haven't showered.
Nobody gives a what you have to say." We don't have all of the
body language and typical.
>> The person she's complained most about being critical
of her is literally Queenman. Now, I can't comment on the smell,
but neither of those other two things are true. She's like trying
to shoehorn people into this caricature she's building, right?
>> She's trying to make it seem like, oh, if you're critical
of me, you are >> Well, actually, everyone that hates her
is actually very attractive.
>> And then she also doesn't even acknowledge that I was
critical of her. That's how she's just gotten past that >> She
just ignores it. Yeah.
>> And I'm I'm on video. My My YouTube I I came on video.
I'm not fat or stinky. I I look pretty good. >> I'm sure
Erdite's just getting around to it. She's going to see the video
soon.
>> Yeah, of course. >> Yeah, I'm sure. >> Right
when she explains what a whistleblower is.
saying this is like cut to the arite haters and it's just like
a legion of like you know uber mench likely
youth
>> social cues that we have to go oh that person's a dumbass
and their opinion about this situation shouldn't be listened
to. If you were ever anywhere socially public
everyone would immediately realize how weird it is. The problem
is that people don't even realize that it's the same person saying
all of this weird [__] all the time. We just need
to realize who these people are. You just need to put a face
on it. The like Reddit mod thing, I don't even like like the
image of it because a lot of them aren't like fat. A lot of them
are just like normal people who are like really insecure and
angry and take it out online because they can't can't take it
out in their >> You just made fun of them like eight different
times in this video. But actually, guys, I know I just called
you all fat lossers like eight times, but realistically, you're
just normal people with self-confidence issues. Wonder where
those came from. >> Jobs because they haven't gone to therapy
and just worked through their anger like a normal person. >> Anyways,
I'm not soite. Thanks for tuning in. Don't forget to like show
her therapy finding service. No. >> So, not a just tipped
$5. You can hate watch me yet you sit fat obese on your >> Thank
you for the five. Where is that line from?
That's from something. >> The donation was like you can
but you you you can hate watch me but you sit there fat obese
on your couch. You sit there fat. I feel like that's from something.
Wait, did she literally say that on her? Oh, in her Charlie Kirk
video,
dude. I was like, where's that quote from? I didn't believe it.
Damn. >> You can join my memberships, but always, always,
always the best way that you can support me,
join the Patreon. Thanks. >> Oh, so true, guys. patreon.com/jstlk
prestream poststream content. We've actually done a couple Patreon
calls recently. All right. patreon.com/jdlk.
Join many Discord perks. You guys want to help? Go to the Patreon.
Join the Patreon. Become members of the Patreon.
Thank you guys very much. Appreciate it. Onelegged pants. I think
they're not pants. I think there's no pants. I think it's like
a or something. Leotard I go. I do now have subscriber mode enabled
on Instagram. I don't know what I'm going to put on there. >> We'll
figure it out. But Patreon is the best way you can support me.
You can join the book club. We also do a DBT workshop in there.
And uh join the community of Discord if you uh so dare. Just
remember they're not all as nice as people. DBT.
>> Wow. DBT workshop. Crazy. >> So you're doing therapy.
Do you have your license? >> It's a workshop. They're they're
doing skills. They're learning skills. Well, if you guys join
our uh Patreon, I am doing a therapy course
if anyone's
>> Fat juicy juvenile vagina.
Fat juicy. >> Okay,
that's her reading the Ethan Klein thing. That's her reading
the Ethan Klein thing. Gross. Gross. Gross. Gross. All right.
I think unless there's anything else, I think we're basically
done for the night. Let me see here. Let me see. Let me see.
>> Bro, I >> Why did she release a video on like
a thoroughly mocked and debunked legal mindset video?
>> I just feel like
Yeah,
I don't Someday people will learn not to just grab legal mindset
videos and
and echo them.
Okay, before we log off, I just have to make sure Queenman saw
the Amaranth tweet that Teone seeds about.
>> You see this tweet?
>> Here. Uh, Teone Teone decided to mock her and her husband.
Okay. Some clip of them. Uh, your wife shows herself nude to
every dude on the planet for a dollar, but the husband can't
watch strippers. I thought being a prostitute was empowering.
Goofy ass double
Hamaranth responds, "Assuming that because she is an only fans,
she must be down for anything from her man is how you got into
the mess you're in with Pinky Chu. Stay in your lane and focus
on being on beating your case, bro."
And then he >> went and did his video on Lwig and he seethed
about people lying about him. >> Well, I mean, that's every
video, but I I I'm guessing this one was especially
>> Well, Lwig has gone on record.
>> Just the black one. I got I got to find it specifically.
>> Uh the lies or lying mom man.
Where was it? I have to I just have to find it really quickly.
understand that I deeply deeply get underneath these people's
skins. And the reason why is because I'm an easy dunk. And the
reason why I'm an easy dunk >> is because enough people
have pretended that factually incorrect information is truthful.
as well as many of the popular uh streaming gossip sites where
astroturfed or negative agendas were pushed by very large streamers
at the time. But that's okay. Their career will soon come to
an end, I'm sure. While I will remain, as I am, a very constant
in this community.
>> So that is he feels like he can respond to people on
Twitter. He gets under people's skin and he they they get mad
at him or they hit him back because of lies they tell about him.
Yeah, it's just he he was he was talking Amra totally [__]
>> the black woman part. >> The black woman. Oh,
right.
>> Tetown could clear all this up by simply responding
to the Shimu videos. >> Part you need I said I've said
multiple times now. You have to you have to commit to this. Okay.
If he responds tangibly to the Shimu videos, we will cut rap
tone out of the vocabulary
>> I will stop saying rapetone.
I'll convince everyone around me to stop.
I I commit fully. I commit fully. >> Answer these questions.
I'll stop saying rape tone. Okay. Answ Go talk about the Shamu
videos. Go watch them. I actually said if Asmin Gold did it,
too. If Asminold watches those full Shamu
>> I would stop saying rapetone. I would >> To quote
to quote every black woman ever, I'm a real ass [__]
in this fake ass world. Yes.
>> Uh, does this have I mean, do you have sound right now?
>> No, it's it's working now. I think it's just my headphones
dying. >> Yeah, I was about to say that is Hugh. That's
Hugh Anthony all the way through. That is major Hugh Anthony
energy.
>> Does he even know any black women? Not that he'll admit
probably.
>> Okay. I hate to leave end on a destiny note. I have
no idea. Ri just sent me some logs. I don't know what this would
be. Uh, good luck brave mess. The only thing crazier the only
crazier thing that could happen to me in or sorry happened in
my life at this point would is me getting murder. Oh, sorry.
Sorry. Hold on. Wrong way. Wrong way.
Pop down guys. Holy. Just ask me in 6 months. Bookmark this one.
The only crazier thing that could happen in my life at this point
is me getting murdered. Good luck brave me.
And then apparently he's taking two weeks off.
So, it's going great with Empath channel, I'm guessing. >> No
idea. No idea. But I don't know. I don't know if he got served.
I don't know what the [__] going on, but
we'll
I'm sure.
She's literally crazy. She is literally crazy. Yes. Then posted
those logs hours. Those logs then posted those logs 12 hours
later. Which logs?
What? >> I'm going to dip out for this. >> Okay.
All right. See you later.
wildly speculate about what's about what's going on now then
let's wildly speculate about what's going on >> you want
to wildly speculate Whoops
do Patreon thing
what do you think
uh
so I feel like not I don't think it's >> clear real real
quick he said he was going to stream then he didn't then posted
those logs hours later 12 hours later So just just so you know
the
Okay. If if I'm getting that much background, what else was going
on? Like was he coming back from somewhere? Where where was he?
>> He was at I assume he was at the Las Vegas thing, Impath
Chan or whatever. Then he flew back. >> Were they not back
in Miami already
>> Well, he would have been back in Miami cuz he would
be saying he was going to stream.
I assume. >> I thought they were back like two days ago
or something. I thought that's when the pictures were going around.
Uh, I think the pictures were from before they left.
>> I didn't follow that closely. Um,
>> yeah. I mean, >> apparently he did stream today
as well.
>> He did stream today as well. Okay.
So, that that was not true. Okay. >> Oh, okay. Riyle is
saying he streamed the day before and talked about the Impath
Chan stuff from Miami. Then this would have been day two.
>> So, she already left. >> I don't think she went
back with him. Oh, right. Okay. Okay. >> Oh, never mind.
Ri's mixing stuff up. So, it was yesterday he he streamed for
a little bit and did some response to the Impath Gen thing and
then he said, "Unbelievable. Whatever the is going on." So, then
he did stream. He said he was going to stream. He streamed a
little bit and then later in the day he said, "Guys,
uh, crazy [__] Ask me in 6 months." So, now speculate.
I feel like not likely, but where my mind goes is some, you know,
weird with uh what I mean, not really weird at this point, but
some with the government like they're coming down on
either the speech stuff or there's
something happening there that I don't think that's likely. That's
not high up on my
my um
scale. I don't think that's where my mind goes. >> what
could it be, though? What's what's like reasonable? Like super
reasonable.
>> a two weeks off. >> Maybe another
maybe another Oh, maybe one of the deliberations. Maybe something
like Pixie. Maybe she got a subpoena granted or something for
like the past like two years of his logs or something like his
Google Drive or some [__]
>> No. No. Cuz it has to be crazier than that. I feel like
if he's saying the only crazier thing could be getting
I bet it's got to be a little bit crazier than that. Obviously,
he's over he's going to be over, >> but he thinks he's
like the biggest victim all of the time. Like he he's a I agree.
I agree. But I but I feel like it's got to be a little bit more
than that. I feel like it's got to be a little bit more than
that. And for two weeks off as well, like I don't know,
>> I think so. Unless somebody I don't know why I think
this I I don't I can't remember why. I thought he was taking
time off anyway. No.
Wasn't it expected that he was taking time off after this? I
understand the two weeks thing seems serious. I could have sworn
he was going to take time off after this. Willie Max's wife sent
a massage unit to recruit him for the Gillian Mwell reboot. Okay.
Well,
he put the spooky Sunday music on. Wait, which stuff? Oh, cuz
we're speculating. Hold on. Sure. Uh, he went to the UK already,
Riyle. I thought
I don't unfortunately I used to actually keep up on like what
this guy was saying
it's unironically the only it's it's actually just more fun to
watch the people around him than him in any way at this point.
>> Yeah, this works. Speaking of which, just check Con's
channels. Wonder if Connor's got anything funny recently.
apparently in 3 days he's DM he's still or he's supposed to be
debating Muhammad hijab. I haven't heard anything about that.
So other time he took two weeks off is when Pixie filed the lawsuit.
Could be another another lawsuit filed. Could be Molina lawsuit.
Could be
right. Like technically they have the right to file a like a
civil lawsuit. Muhammad hijab. I did not make that up.
That's like a Oxford debate thing. Muhammad hijab versus destiny.
Surprisingly they found one of the few people on planet Earth
who can't really call destiny a Okay. The things this guy's willing
to defend are far more than what he's willing to defend. Okay.
>> I saw the guy who celebrated Charlie Kirk's death got
removed as the president of Oxford uh debate site where it's
called. >> He did. For some reason when I see that guy
I think he looks like Bob Valain, but I've only seen Bob Vol.
Same lanky black guy look. >> Yeah. Lanky black guy dreads.
All right. Well, I listen I tried speculating. I I'm all out
of speculation. I don't know what else could be going on there.
Sorry, the Will Stansel stuff just keeps getting me every time.
It do be like that, Mr. Stansel. It do be like that, Mr. Stansel.
Every single one of these anime characters is going to be saying,
"It do be like that, Mr. Stansel." Right. >> It do be like
that, Mr. Stansel. >> It do be like that, Mr. Stansel.
>> It do be like that, Mr. Stans. >> It do be like
>> It do be like that, Mr. Stansel. >> It do be like
that, Mr. Stans. >> It do be like that, Mr. Stansel. >> It
do be like that, Mr. Stansel. Do be like that, Mr. Stans back
online, Mr.
>> I'll be back. Uh, I think tomorrow's off, guys, but
we'll see after tomorrow. Um, what's going on? All right.
No, no stream tomorrow.
We will be back in the near future. Oh, take ends here. She says,
"Don't raid crisp." Okay, we can raid.
We'll raid Nick. Okay, Nick. Oh, Nick's sleeping. We'll raid
low tier god.
Raiding low tier god. All right, have a good night, guys. Go
see look to your god. We'll talk to you'all later. Okay.